foreign
[Music]
you know I've never been a fan of you
too I don't know if if I've ever even
met a fan of their music I don't think
anyone has ever liked you two and yet
they are one of the most successful
musical acts in the history of the world
it's not clear exactly how they managed
to pull this off they became you might
say the world's elevator music or maybe
society's hold music something you hear
all the time whether you like it or not
and you don't really like it but you
also don't necessarily hate it the music
just is it exists and it exists
everywhere and nobody knows why and
nobody ever asks
and nobody can distinguish one U2 song
from another no one can we all we know
every U2 song and yet we don't know any
of them it's one of the most confounding
riddles of Life The Man Behind this
mystery Bono was profiled yesterday in
the New York Times in a piece titled
Bono is still trying to figure out U2
and himself
it only deepens the mystery to discover
that the lead singer of the band also
doesn't know why it exists or why
anybody likes it as for figuring out
himself Bono is in his mid-60s now it's
probably time to start arriving at a few
conclusions before it's too late he's
apparently written a memoir which
explains why he was doing the New York
Times interview most of the interview
doesn't interest me but there is one
admission
that did interest me he says this quote
I ended up as an activist in a very
different place from where I started I
thought that if we just redistributed
resources then we could solve every
problem
I now know that's not true
there's a funny moment when you realize
as an activist the off ramp out of
extreme poverty is
Ugg Commerce it's entrepreneurial
capitalism
imagine that
who could have ever guessed it's
capitalism now I will say that you know
I don't treat capitalism like a religion
as some establishment conservative types
have done historically I believe in the
free market I don't think that our free
market principles though should preclude
us from doing things like regulating big
Tech holding it accountable for the ways
that it censors and suppresses speech I
also don't think that defending the free
market must necessarily mean that we
have to be Ardent Defenders of Behemoth
transnational corporations
the relationship between government
corporations big Tech media the kind of
systemic Human Centipede as I have
previously described it is is is is such
that the phrase free market barely even
applies to these institutions they've
all become like quasi-governmental
institutions in their own way further I
don't think that being a capitalist
means that we must surrender our culture
to smut and filth insisting that any
effort to enforce basic standards of
human decency is somehow an assault on
the free market or on Free Speech so
these are all important caveats perhaps
caveat isn't the right word they are
more so specifications or descriptions
of what I mean when I talk about
capitalism and the descriptions are
important because not everyone means the
same thing in fact Bono himself
transitions immediately from admitting
that capitalism is the best way out of
poverty to making a sales pitch for
globalization he conflates the two
globalization and capitalism but they're
not the same thing that is a specific
sort of capitalism the type that a
left-wing multi-millionaire celebrity is
destined to support but it's not the
only option
and in the case of impover impoverished
third world countries what they need
most is not globalization but a
legitimate local economy with thriving
small businesses and so on
so with all that said
um Bono is correct in the fundamental
Revelation at which he has arrived about
60 years late
that the way out of poverty is through
entrepreneurial capitalism
he's wrong though that this is separate
this is somehow a separate concept from
redistributing resources and that's kind
of a false choice because one way or
another resources are going to be if you
want to put it this way redistributed
that's because there are finite
resources available there's a certain
amount of food a certain amount of
houses the cars certain amount of uh
capital in the world there are a lot of
these things and more can be produced
and are produced every day but the
amount is still finite as opposed to
infinite it's just another way of saying
that you can't make all of your
necessities and your desired luxuries
materialize out of thin air if you want
something or you need something you have
to obtain it it must be transferred or
distributed
if you like into your possession
the only other option is to build
Harvest or hunt it yourself but very few
people in the modern world can live an
entirely self-sustaining life and it's
not generally a path to prosperity and
besides even if you go that route you
still need to obtain some of the tools
necessary to do it successfully so the
question becomes not whether resources
are distributed from one party to
another
everyone agrees on that if you want to
have any kind of economy and every civil
civilized society and even uncivilized
ones must have economies
then that's just the nature of the Beast
and broadly speaking here simplifying to
a significant extent
there there are two ways
of getting the resources from one party
to another
you can do it by plunder and seizure
which is a stronger Force taking the
resources it wants and giving it to
whoever they determine starting of
course with themselves
or you can do it through a Marketplace
or a one party obtains the desired good
or service from another party and an
exchange pays an agreed upon price
neither of these systems are perfect
both can be abused
there will be poverty in both
unscrupulous people will find ways to
exploit the vulnerable in either case
but the question is which system opens
up the best path to human flourishing
while offering fewer opportunities for
exploitation and depression and the
answer as history has always shown is
the latter
the free market approach which offers
the most Freedom the most flourishing
and will be the most likely to lift
people out of poverty
the problem with the season plunder
system whether it's a governmental
entity doing it or Pirates or Vikings or
a rival tribe or whoever is that you're
relying on their benevolence
to identify the parties who need the
resources more and then deliver it
you're also relying on their perfect
wisdom to know who deserves what
you are depending on them to have God's
goodness and generosity and wisdom to go
along with the god-like powers that they
are wielding and that faith is always
100 of the time misplaced this is why
communism and socialism and all forms of
governmental redistribution systems end
in misery and catastrophe
one of the problems with progressives
like Bono is that they don't respect or
understand nature
and that applies to external nature the
planet's nature the nature comprised of
trees and oceans and clouds
it also applies to internal nature Human
Nature they respect and understand that
least of all
they don't understand that human beings
are Fallen creatures and so all of our
institutions will be at some level
broken and unreliable and so we can't
give absolute power to any Institution
the institutions that they can't carry
the weight of that sort of trust and
faith
they also don't understand
Tendencies and Trends and the ways in
which historical Trends can and should
guide our expectations of the future
the left just doesn't understand this
that's why they keep trying to
you know get socialism going again and
again because no matter how much misery
it accounted for in the past it's also
why on the individual level they think
that we ought to continue releasing
violent criminals back into our
communities maybe they've changed maybe
they've been reformed they cried
yeah maybe
but almost certainly not
Anything is Possible
but we have to make policies and
decisions based on what is probable not
what is possible
it's possible that you could jump off of
a 100 story building and survive I mean
it's it's possible technically
it's not impossible it is possible but
it's certainly not probable
the probability is low enough
that it's worth taking the elevator
even if that's a little bit slower
as for economic systems a common citizen
advocating for governmental control is
like jumping out of that window and
hoping that you're the one guy who has a
positive experience with it
on the other hand for the powerful for
the elite
socialism is not a Plunge at all it's an
elevation to even greater Heights
enjoyed at the expense
of all those peons still lingering at
ground level
and who will soon end up lower even than
that
now these are all points quite obvious
to me and to most of you
they were not obvious to Bono until now
I'm glad that he finally got it right
sort of got it right anyway
but unfortunately
for being late to the party
I must still say that he and his music
are canceled
mostly it's just his music though to be
honest that's canceled
all right that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]